it was all hands on deck before setting
sail on a hunt that's been three decades
coming these are the men that will bring
fresh local wheels back to Japan
harpoons are ready and so are the crew
bigger and fatter whales means better
meat well transport it as fresh as
possible so that old people can taste it
and remember the old days communities
like Kushiro stand ready to cash in as
Japan defies international outcry and
pushes ahead with the practice to send
off commercial whaling ships for the
first time in 31 years it's very
emotional for those of us who've been
working for the resumption I'm happy
from the bottom of my heart
in recent years Japan has got its fill
of whale meat through scientific hunts
but locals say it never produced enough
many traditionalists in Japan see
whaling is more of culture than
conservation though not everyone agrees
I've never eaten whale before
I don't know if it tastes good so I'm
wondering if I should buy them or not
nakta more bits in here I don't really
need to eat wheel at another major
whaling town this time and prime
minister shinzo Abbey's own constituency
there were celebrations as the crew set
off in a bed to help revive Japan's
controversial love affair with whale
meat let's bring a Nicholas n trip from
ocean care a marine conservation
organization in Vienna Nicholas thank
you for joining us we should mention
that Japan has still been whaling of the
last few decades but officially for
scientific purposes so what does today
really change okay first of all the name
of the whale hunt changed from
scientific to commercial because
actually the vessels they're using are
the same vessels they have been using
however there is a huge significant
difference now is Japan is left
International Whaling Commission they've
left the institution that is responsible
to regulate whaling and that has decided
in 1982 whale species should no longer
be hunted for commercial purposes
Japan hasn't got what it wanted over the
years so it left his institution and is
now wailing outside the international
body that should regulate it so that's
quite a devastating situation what has
happened over the last 30 years did the
whale population recover sufficiently in
that time it's a very good question
because some whale species and some
whale populations did recover actually
but not those we are talking about in
Japan I give you an example the most
abundant wave species in those motors is
the minke whale in a Northwest Pacific
however science tells us that the minke
whale is divided in certain populations
and one population is highly endangered
so when a whale approaches a minke whale
on the water and kills it it cannot
differentiate is this an endangered
whale or is this a non endangered whale
it's death and you finally will we'll
find out about the genetics so very
often you find endangered whales or
whales from endangered populations on
the market and that's quite an appalling
situation Nicholas the Japanese
perspective here is that this is a
long-running tradition a part of their
culture can you understand
perspective no I don't because actually
I think I think it's it's kind of a PR
rhetoric because the whaling we see
today is kind of a product of the Second
World War when there was a need in terms
of providing protein to the people but
what we've seen over the past decades
has been a deep a significant decrease
in interest in demand etc so what what
the the whaling the pro Whalers are
facing is in non existing market and
what will happen now is that the
government will spend lots of money to
create an artificial demand you know
they will promote whale products in
schools etc and I think that's really
the wrong way to go what we would like
to see is a face out of that of that
activity but Nicholas why would the
Japanese government want to do that
create an artificial market where there
isn't one well it's it's very simple
because they've told the people for 30
years that this is what they want and
this is you know the end and they gave
it a kind of an artificial cultural
identity which we believe doesn't really
exist in that respect you know ask the
young people that the the long say the
young citizens in Japan you will not see
much support for it
and I think the big question is what on
one hand will the Japanese public you
know give a blind eye to whale products
and I really hope so
but the other thing is Japan has left
international negotiation table and
that's a really boring trend the u.s.
left a Paris agreement Japan leaves the
whaling commission what's next all right
Nicholas enter from ocean care in Vienna
thank you very much for your analysis
okay I thank you for the invitation